hi there steve kaufman here
[Music]
hi there just before i get into my main
uh
discussion today i just wanted to update
you on my 90-day challenge
um
so you can see the statistics uh i'm not
you know i would like to get to where i
get five or 600 new words every week
that's going to get me to where i want
to be in terms of comprehension i'm not
able to do that i'm actually creating
more and more
uh links so i'm adding to the sort of
you know words that i've come across
that i want to convert to known
and
you know plus i'm playing more golf the
weather's been good i don't know how
long the weather's going to stay good so
i play golf with my wife so obviously
when we're learning languages we do have
other things in our lives other than
learning languages and we want to make
sure that when we're learning languages
we're totally you know into that
activity
the other thing is there's always this
conflict between
trying to move words to known which is
going to require going over stuff that
you've already gone over
versus the attraction of new podcasts
from al jazeera
so and i'll get into more of that later
on but that's to explain why i'm kind of
a little disappointed with my statistics
this week today i want to talk about a
subject that comes up a lot
with english speakers who are learning
other languages and that is that they
are in the country where the language is
spoken they speak to someone in the
language that they're learning which is
the language of the country and the
person replies in english and this is a
bit
discouraging and what can we do about it
and so forth so i want to talk about
that subject but first i remind you that
if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe you can
click or tap on the bell to get
notifications and i would also encourage
you to come and join us at link and
learn language is the way i learn
languages
now
so i saw a tweet and and by the way i do
enjoy twitter because it is kind of fun
to connect to people all over the world
as i do in different languages and and
see what people are concerned about
talking about some of it has to do with
language some of the some of it has to
do with with politics or interests that
people have and so forth so anyway
there's this tweet it's so discouraging
says someone that you know i speak to
someone in the language that i'm
learning and they reply in english and
this happens of course very often in
places where the standard of english is
very high say germany
it happens but it can happen anywhere it
can happen when the person you're
speaking to for whatever reason wants to
use english it may be because you're
german japanese whatever isn't very good
it may be because that person feels
their
english is better than your level in
that language and therefore it's more
practical to speak in english it may be
because that person wants to practice
their english
just as you want to practice your
language
and you know if we turn the tables
around
um you know first of all that'll happen
mostly to english speakers obviously if
you are a speaker of say
russian and you're in england and you
speak to someone in english they are
highly unlikely to reply to you in
russian that would be a very
amazing coincidence that your random
person in england or in the united
states or even in france speaks russian
so obviously this is something that
happens much more to
english speakers who are learning other
languages
and but if we turn things around i often
find that say here in canada if i
come across someone who i think is
korean or
iranian or whatever and and i can
sometimes guess by their appearance or
their name or whatever then i try to
address them in that language
i know that often that's not really
appreciated because their
perspective is i live in canada what's
the matter you think my english is no
good
they want to actually speak english so
and and i had the same i have the same
say when i'm down south in california i
find someone with a spanish name and
even a spanish accent they're not
necessarily happy that i address them in
spanish so there's always this sort of
conflict of interest one party wants to
speak one language the other party wants
to speak another language
so what can you do well first of all i
think the main goal of any communication
is communication
so probably if i were honest here if i
address someone who is working say as a
clerk in a store or as a waiter or
something that the more practical thing
is to speak english
although very often i elicit a very
happy response
say from
an iranian person it's kind of 50 50.
50 50 of the time they come back in in
english
uh even while they tell me oh that's
nice that you have studied the ring or
you know farsi or persian sometimes
they'll come back in person so it's 50
50.
um
but in any case i don't think it's a
very important thing similarly if you
say are studying german and you go to
germany and you go in a store and you
ask for something in german and they
reply in english
that's not very important and i think my
main message on this subject is
the random person you come across
is not a major
you know language
opportunity if you're with friends
and they're all speaking german and you
happen to be with them
uh if you're german is so poor that
every time you are involved in the
conversation they have to switch to
english that's not good that's more a
reflection of your level of german
on the other hand if you're going to a
store and the clerk for whatever reason
because they want to practice their
english because they think you're german
is not very good they reply in english
not a big deal in my opinion however
what can you do well you can continue to
speak in german if you're in germany
however if i'm in canada and the person
replies
in
and i speak say in persian and they
reply in english
i might try again with my persian but if
they insist on speaking in english i
just speak in english because
to my mind you know ultimately
you know what am i trying to achieve in
my language learning it's not the
ability to have a random encounter with
someone at some point in my language
learning as if to confirm that i can
speak the language it doesn't matter to
me my goal is
yeah have the odd fun surprising people
in the language
or using the language
if it works if they accept
you know that i'm going to speak to them
in that language and if they don't
accept it fine and dandy
to me it's more important that i'm able
to understand podcasts understand movies
uh hopefully look forward to the day
when i can be in a genuine
meaningful conversation with people on a
variety of subjects and handle my end of
it
in the language that final goal that's
what matters
it's not a matter of you know oh i spoke
to someone in german and they responded
replied in english i just don't see that
as a major as a major issue yet it's
something that comes up all the time so
i guess
there we we
you know we can continue i think the
only thing we can do is to continue to
work to improve our level in the
language
t b not take it so seriously because
they have just as much right to practice
their english as you have to practice
your german or persian in my case
and c look at your goals do is is the
ultimate goal to be able to have a
random conversation in the language or
is it to be able to access the full
range of of culture and
movies and experience that you can have
in the language down the road and if
that's the case then this random
opportunity where you are unable to use
the language you're learning
really doesn't have that much importance
so that's my thought on that subject
[Music]
you